uh pin bar do we need to worry about
insect at this early stage do we need to
spray no why not at this stage the the
insect damage is can be completely
compensated for by the plant so normally
the things you get at the early stage
are things like Leaf
folder little bit of Lea folder and whal
maggot wh maggot actually is the biggest
problem this time of year but as the
plant GR it just it just disappears
because the plant as the leaves get
thicker the maggots can't actually eat
the leaf but you know I I keep worrying
I see things on the leaves like this
here and some things chewed on it this
is a wh maggot that's a wh maggot yeah
there nothing to worry about no problem
no problem is yeah in fact this is even
light it's not even uh you know a normal
infestation of world
maggot what is this here there's a some
egg M on it here what these are these
are probably some sort of paracoid that
has so it's a wasp cocoon and these are
beneficial again so it's good news uh
these will fly off there's about 40 of
them there so they'll fly off then and
parasitize things like Leaf folder
um larvea or um other caterpillars so
they're again a beneficial
insect fin bar I saw already saw a few
lady beetles is what I would call them
are they are they playing much of a role
at this early they're also very
important they're also feeding on on the
natural of the the herbivore insects so
they eat eggs mainly um also good uh
predators of apids and also the
dragonfly there's a lot of dragonfly
flying around one of the things when you
think about insects and rice you have to
remember that in the water another
problem generated by rice is mosquitoes
and the dragonfly larva live in the
water they have a very big uh strong jaw
and they pre on the dragon on the uh
mosquito Lara so they're keeping your
mosquitoes down so really there's a
whole ecosystem here functioning to keep
everything in order I mean one really
has to look hard to see all these things
I see a little spider web here in which
some some little insects are caught in
there what are those these are those
midges that are flying around these are
the decomposer midg so they're again uh
beneficial and spiders are very
important
predators of things like plant oppers
mainly plant hoers so but but you know
when I look around I see lots of crits
here know insects of all kinds little
things flying or crawling or so is that
one of the reasons that some Farmers
think they have to spray because they
see all these insects well a lot of
people don't understand what these
insects are doing so a lot of people
when they see these swarms of midges for
example that are decomposing the the
material they think it's a PL and
they'll spray uh the same with the World
mag one of the biggest problems with
world magga is that it it induces
Farmers to spray but we never see any
yield reduction the same with um uh Leaf
folder looking quite good Lee do you
have any worries about insects when do
we need to start worrying about them
again a little bit in finbar's hands my
knowledge of insects is not particularly
profuse I'm probably more worried about
the rats I think the rats have just
given us an early warning over there
yeah look at this it's all chopped off
seedlings here whole SW chopped out
which uh probably looks like red damage
so some mean red went through here and
uh basically created a total empty patch
here just chopped off on the right on
the on the surface
here horrible not much we can do about
that one